it's hard to write code for retries and
failures in distributed systems but mete
you told me the other day that you have
a solution for this
yes Workforce can help let me show you
how
[Music]
imagine you're building an e-commerce
application
you need to receive orders and make sure
customers have enough credit before you
process the order
you could have two micro services
order service receives a request and
creates a pending order
customer service tries to reserve the
credit and if successful order service
approves a pending order so the order
service would call the customer service
yes you could have Services calling each
other directly but I don't recommend it
direct calls create unnecessary coupling
between services
for example if you need to change
customer service you need to think about
if ordering service needs to change as
well makes sense and how can we avoid
that coupling you can use a service
orchestrator to Define which service
needs to be called in what order and let
the orchestrator make those calls that
way Services don't know about each other
and they don't call each other directly
Google cloud has workflows for service
orchestration sounds like that would
mean less code for me to write and I
like that because I know that any code I
write will contain bugs and I will have
to maintain it in the future but how do
I tell workflows what to do and in what
order
let's take a look at the yaml file that
defines orchestration
here we have the assign step where we
initialize the URLs we want to call
we are calling the alwaysworks endpoint
in customer service it's an endpoint
that never fails
in this step we call the order service
to create a pending order
in the next step we call the customer
service to reserve the credit
in the final step we call the order
service again to approve the order
got it and what would happen if we run
this let's run it here I am in the
workflow let's hit execute
and as expected
it works
and it will always work because we are
calling the endpoint that never fails
which never happens in real life right
and speaking of real life if the call to
Reserve credit fails the whole workflow
stops
yeah unfortunately yes in our first
implementation of the orchestration if
any of the steps fail then the whole
orchestration fails and we may not want
that right definitely not we need to
think about how to handle failures and
that depends on the nature of the
failure for example let's say The
Reserve credit endpoint in customer
service is flaking it fails once in a
while due to some transient error right
right there could be network errors for
example how would we handle that one is
a way of handling transient errors is to
apply a retry policy instead of calling
an endpoint once you can retry two or
three times if it fails Aha and what
would the yaml look like for that let me
show you the second version we're
calling this sometimes works endpoint
now this endpoint throws errors once in
a while here we wrap the HTTP call with
the default with right policy I see and
what happens if we run that let's run it
and see what happens as you see the
workflow is successful even though we
were calling this sometimes works
endpoint that can fail once in a while
and this takes care of transient errors
like if the customer service is down
temporarily but what if the customer has
no credit so Reserve credit always fails
right that is certainly possible and we
need to handle that differently as
that's more of a permanent error if the
customer has no credit uh reprise won't
help that's when The Saga pattern can
come into play ah Saga pattern I've
heard and read about that term before
and it has something to do with the
compensation stuff right matter yes the
idea is when a service call fails you
need to decide if you need to take a
compensation step to undo a previous
call in this case order service creates
the pending order if the customer
service cannot Reserve credit the
pending order needs to be canceled
that's the compensation step on the
other hand if the customer service
Reserve credit code is successful you go
ahead and upload the order
and the workflow would still retry The
Reserve credit call if there are
transient errors like before that's
right let's take a look at the ammo now
we have an accept block
in that block we check for
non-recoverable errors and then go to
reject pending order
to cancel the order that's our
compensation step
and what does it look like when we run
this let's run it
it executes successfully and it will
continue to execute because it recovers
from transient errors and compensates
for non-recurable errors and you call
this The Saga pattern yes the Saga
pattern is often used in distributed
systems where you cannot use database
transactions you start with assuming
things will work well if they don't you
compensate in later steps by undoing
what you did before it's eventually
consistent
I like that approach to life we assume
things will work we Define the workflow
declaratively instead of in imperative
code and we compensate if things go
wrong thanks for showing us mete thanks
for having me it was fun
and thank you everyone for watching if
you have any questions for a matter
about the clarity workflows or The Saga
pattern leave them in the comments and
let me know in the comments if you have
suggestions for other serverless topics
I should bring up in the future I read
every single comment until next time
[Music]
thank you